[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Open the Cloud Storage
browser in the Google Cloud
Platform Console and
click Create bucket.
Give the bucket a
globally unique name.
This name is publicly
visible, so don't
include sensitive information.
Choose Regional
for storage class,
and choose us-east1
for location.
Click Create, which
will create your bucket.
Now that we've created a
bucket, let's upload an image
into the new bucket.
Click Upload files and select
the file you want to store.
After the upload
completes, you should
see the file name, size,
type, and last modified
date in the bucket.
In order to share the file,
create a publicly accessible
URL for it.
Click the dropdown menu
associated with the file
and select Edit permissions.
Click the Add item button.
In the new row that's
added, enter User
for the Entity column.
Enter allUsers in
the Name column,
and enter Reader in
the Access column.
Click Save.
You'll now see there's a
link icon for the object.
Clicking it will reveal
the object's public URL.
Now your file is online
for everyone to see.
Congratulations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]